all right i am going live just a little
bit early this time around because we've
already got some questions lined up in
the corner
and i decided to let my hair down since
i uh i just got out of the shower and i
need to get it to dry a little bit more
and it's nice not to bind it up so
tightly all the time so i'm going to
start answering questions in just a
minute waiting for people
to stream in
and glad to have all of you here i'll
say that it's always
fun doing these this is a particularly
nice weekend for for me in part because
it's uh i've got a few things
planned but not too much work and i
think i'll get to go out and about in
the city in just a little while and
maybe take a walk and take some pictures
and stuff like that
all right it's getting close to the
start of the hour so let me start on the
first question which is an interesting
one um from isaac
do you think it's fair that camus and
heidegger are often placed under the
existentialist umbrella despite both
refuting the label if so why
totally fair uh you know consider
whether
hume would be you know whether it's fair
to call him an empiricist or whether
it's fair to call spinoza a rationalist
even though they may not have used those
terms
there's you know when we're looking at
language we have to understand that
terms
don't just have one single fixed meaning
they
they mean multiple things and
existentialist is both a
term that can have a very precise
meaning in which case you're taught what
you're talking about with heidegger and
camus and also i should point out marcel
the first person to use the word
existentialist in french
not refuting but refusing is what you
meant um
there's that sense and then there's the
broad sense in which we're talking about
you know a movement of thought and they
are existentialist i'm going to turn on
some lights here because it's notice
it's kind of dark in this uh this area
they are existentialists in in that
broad sense and i have no problem
calling heidegger an existentialist he
uses the words existential over and over
again in his works
camus when he's talking about the
existentialists he has some very precise
people in mind but he's he's doing the
same themes as
many of the other existentialists so
there's zero problem doing that and
um this comes up over and over again
people think that that you know um
the fact that that sartre tried to
control effectively and gatekeeped the
term
and then these other people were like
we're not playing your game buddy
including marcel and heidegger uh should
be important but no when we're teaching
and we're talking about broad movements
and philosophy it's perfectly fine
to you know use these uh
you know capital e existentialist terms
like that
uh dammit albert says some religion
teachers suggest children ought not to
be taught religion by parents while
they're young due to the influence it
can have on them
versus when it's done in a controlled
environment uh meaning a classroom like
yours that strikes me as a very stupid
point of view for religion teachers to
have and it's probably a result of
bigotry on their part or just ignorance
um you know about how things actually
work in the real world i mean if you
think that that children are not going
to be getting messages about religion
from the general culture before they get
into a classroom environment
you're crazy
um and i i actually think that it's
great for parents to teach kids
something about religion
because that way at least they have
something to when they're teenagers and
rebellious to reject and to push against
right now obviously we don't want
religion as abusive indoctrination
but you know that's that's
less often the case and much more often
the case is a kind of lukewarm know
nothing well let's just go to class you
know communion and ccd i don't know why
we're doing any of this stuff but it's
just what we do that's much more common
in my experience um and i mean who are
the teachers to think that somehow they
are the ones who are providing the
definitive take on
religion this seems just me very
unworkable
i wouldn't say that my peers in
religious studies are
you know necessarily the best bunch to
be teaching things it's kind of a wide
spectrum so yeah i don't really i don't
really uh buy into that
uh colomous any thoughts about the
intersection of climate with politics
and ethics well there ought to be a lot
more intersection and and not the kind
of refusal oh there is no no climate
issue happening i mean this is what this
is an existential issue in the other
sense of the term meaning that if we
don't figure it out we're all dead
human culture is over
uh if we don't get our act together and
we can't act uh in in concerted ways
and the selfishness and foolishness of a
lot of people is standing in the way
so yeah there's lots of intersections
between those
um
idk what do you think about dark
enlightenment and ccru thinkers like
mark fisher and others i haven't read
mark fisher's
um work so all i can do is you know go
by like thumbnail sketches of it it
seems like you know an interesting idea
um you know if we're talking about the
idea that uh capitalism is the the
milieu that we're stuck in anyway
okay i mean
um fukuyama said that as well years ago
so that by itself doesn't strike me as
all that um
interesting of a thesis um dark
enlightenment dark enlightenment is a
sort of a repetition of the the
bullshitting around that we saw
um in the early 20th century in a lot of
authors you know when i was first
reading mentious mold bug back
man this was uh
that's before i left indiana so
um
before 2008
i was like well there's really little
new about this other than the
terminology it's interesting that you
can repackage this stuff
this traditionalist stuff and then add a
few new interesting twists and put it on
the internet and people will be like oh
my god this is so new you know
um
so that's i mean that's my take uh
on on the dark enlightenment stuff it's
interesting to look at but it's it's
ultimately i don't think a way forward
for anybody
unless you're you're into that sort of
me against the world you know kind of
kind of thing
nl do you have any opinions about walter
kaufman um i mean i like walter kaufman
um
you know i enjoy
reading his uh his little asides as he's
translating things he was kind of a
a big deal back when i was a
undergraduate student but that's just
because my professors were so behind the
times
[Music]
mark smith uh
hope you hope you're doing well look
forward to these amas yeah i always look
forward to seeing mark here um
all right massacre do you think that
science oversteps on trying to answer
fundamentally philosophical questions
like the question of free will god
beginning of the universe do you think
science could ever answer it so there is
no such thing as science um as a single
thing there are scientists there are
sciences there are all sorts of pro
practices and processes and no one
single person like has a grasp on all of
what's going on with with science
um very often when we see people making
claims that are
invoking science that are about free
will or god you know
those sorts of things they're not
actually doing science they're doing
pseudoscience um a lot of neuroscience
is pseudoscience
unfortunately and probably will remain
so for a long time or they're they're
doing science reporting where they're
reading somebody else's studies and then
in order to make it sexy and interesting
they're like taking a tiny little
conclusion about a very small group and
blowing it up into we have no free will
or silly stuff like that
and then there's the you know
sciencey
popular writers who go way beyond their
boundaries and so you know should we
should we criticize science for that no
because those people aren't really doing
science
um they're they're going beyond the
scope of legitimate science and we also
have to clarify what do we mean by
science um depending on what language
and culture we're in science might
include
uh
you know
linguistics or history or philosophy you
know um there's there's a
these sort of questions are are rather
hard to to answer in the way that
they're they're framed
um
quark mars what readings if any would
you recommend to someone studying
social and political foundations of
education which on education types books
essays i mean i'm not i'm not a
philosophy of education person so i'm
i'm not really a great person to ask
about that
but um
you know i would say offhand
of course plato's
plato's works not just the republic but
some of the other ones read aristotle he
has a lot of stuff to say about
education particularly in book three of
the rhetoric and we can just like move
on forward through the ages
into all sorts of uh other things all
the way down to the present i mean john
dewey of course is a big person but i i
kind of like overdosed on dewey when i
was
in graduate school because i went to
southern illinois university where uh
lots and lots of people are into dewey
and so i i you know whenever people
mention him i always have a little
kind of
taste but you know he's an important
philosopher
for that so i don't know i'm not i'm not
really
uh somebody to to survey the field on
that
um
galen did you ever in your medieval
philosophy readings ever do any reading
in saint bonaventure any thoughts do you
consider him more just a theologian so i
will say this i don't buy the hard and
fast distinction between philosophy and
theology that a lot of people like to
make so the notion of just a theologian
i think that's kind of kind of [ __ ]
myself
because um you know the same thing can
be looked at in both philosophical and
theological ways right we don't want to
be too doctrinaire about that yeah i
read bond adventure um i'm not i'm not
that into him you know
um i've i haven't uh you know read
extensively in him but
i read some of his stuff a while back
i'm i probably
should go back to him and re-read him
but this time around when i'm teaching
medieval philosophy i'm actually
teaching just from augustine
up to bernard claravo and hildegard of
bingham uh just you know the early
people and
benedictines i'm not teaching any
franciscans or dominicans
and i'm not really going too far into
the high middle ages frankly
so i don't know when i'll get to reading
him again
uh osh do i have any thoughts on later
heidegger in comparison with his early
period i i prefer the early period stuff
myself
um but i don't see a radical break or
distinction you know the kara is still
the same guy
kara means turning is still the same guy
turning in a different direction right
and so um
you know there's there's some cool stuff
in there
um
[Music]
but you know i i don't i don't think we
have to make too much of this this
massive
distinction uh it's not like say early
wittgenstein and late wittgenstein you
know where late wittgenstein is like wow
that guy was was really screwing up and
this tractatus stuff you know forget
about that right
um
all right uh edwin mayer said thoughts
on lumetri and descartes i don't really
remember that much about lumetri other
than you know the notion of man is
machine so there's nothing for me to say
about that
western man if you sum up the difference
between heidegger and hegel in one
sentence what would that be i wouldn't
sum it up in one sentence so
that doesn't really uh
make sense for for me i mean two very
complex thinkers
uh i mean heidegger came after eagle
here you go that that might be all that
we can do with that
um
let's see here
latham tried to read baudrillard
expecting something interesting is he
just a bad writer or am i missing
something
both
baldriart you are missing something in
baudrillard
and he's a bad writer but he's not a bad
writer in the sense of like in an
objectively bad way where it's rooted in
who he is and you just can't write
the problem is
it has to do with french writing post
1950. and beaudrillard is just sort of a
typical representative of that and you
can find some elements of that earlier
than you know the 50s but
for the most part when you look at
french writing in the early 20th century
it's pretty clear i mean it may be very
embellished it may be expressing quite
complex thoughts you know people used to
criticize maurice blondell for being
like hegel and being like cicero and
writing these massive sentences that are
actually a whole paragraph
but if you spend your time on it you can
figure out what's going on
and then you know
all these plays on words and you know
trying to make texts speak in in many
different ways to the reader that comes
about after the the 1950s and through
the 1950s and i would say you know other
people that fall into that obviously
darida the lose succumbs to that
sometimes foucault can be very precious
that way roland bart you know jacques
lacan was kind of an [ __ ] in doing
that himself
um there's there's a lot of that going
on well and we can we don't have to just
bash guys we could talk about chris
david or rigore and sisu and all of them
it became like the way to talk jean-luc
mario is is you know sometimes subject
to that sort of thing to take a
contemporary thinker um
and so no it's it's it's there is
something there you have to work to get
it they're gonna make you to work to get
it they're do they make it unnecessarily
difficult for you to do that and it's a
it's a kind of gatekeeping you know
frankly uh within their little world and
within the world of people who spend
their their time and life invested in
talking about um late 20th century
french philosophy unfortunately so
yeah that's that's my take on that as
somebody who's been reading that stuff
for 30 years you know and almost wrote
my dissertation on derrida and then
wrote on
maurice blondel
all right uh fabian says i sometimes get
distracted in my philosophy learning
path it's difficult to get back on track
any tips for staying the course
okay so
yeah i do have tips tips going both ways
so let's talk about after you've left
the path right i mean the good thing
about philosophy is that you can always
go back to it
it's not like um
you know the
the schools are going to close and you
miss the boat and now you'll never be
able to to go there there's a helicopter
flying overhead i don't know if you can
all hear that there must be something
going on today or or there's some police
matter um so you know there's there's
there's always the possibility of
getting back into it uh be you know be
gentle with yourself when it comes to
that say listen i
went off the path um i don't have to
like do immediately
exactly what i was doing before it's
enough if i just find some time to read
and
reflect and maybe do a little writing or
things like that
to avoid
falling off the path you know maybe what
you want to do
is what i did with exercise
i was finding
um that although we had a gym membership
to a gym that i really like to go to
i wasn't actually getting to it because
i would say i'm going to go at the end
of the work day and then work would just
pile up through it and i'd be tired and
i'd be like i'll do it i'll do it
tomorrow
so what i started doing
is creating calendar appointments for
myself as if i was meeting with a client
or blocking out some time for reading or
you know whatever else it is that i do
housework cooking you know
and i would treat it as if it's an
appointment that i have to show up for
right and now you could do that with
your philosophical reading you can be
like from seven to nine pm tonight i am
reading
you know
uh william james varieties of religious
experience or i am reading
uh well here's my book
reason fulfilled by revelation right or
whatever
um and and make it into like your your
own appointment with those authors
and
i found that that helped it might not
work for everybody but i i think it
could be helpful for you
um
all right let me check what this super
chat is dan says i wanted to thank you
for hard work on half r hegel
i devoted myself to the phenomenology of
spirit this year and it's been an
invaluable to find videos by paragraph
number
question favorite motorhead album so we
got we got a metal question
um what is that that's so i can i can
tell you the ones that i like the best
are mostly the ones
really running up to the
the mid 80s
um i i like
the later stuff right but
it just doesn't have the same
gripping power as it does for me from
their first maybe like 10 years you
could say
um
i mean i really like bomber
and overkill
um
and then another perfect day is really
good um
i mean i i like ace of spades i like
iron fist those are awesome as well but
i probably would say overkill is my my
favorite one and part because of
overkill but it also has you know these
really
kind of jazzy
trippy things like capricorn
and metropolis right so
yeah
all right let's let's come back to these
other
um
was this o-s-h i think so
um do you think that had heidegger
written a large systematic book of his
later thought like being in time he
would have gotten as famous as he did
early on
i personally find his later area era
wider
um
i mean he is super famous so i don't
think that he had to write a big
book in order to become famous
um there's places where continental
philosophy basically begins with
heidegger
even in the present
so i don't think that's an issue
um i don't find his later era era wider
but that's because i look at the
seminars
that he he provided in his early period
and there's an incredibly wide range of
stuff that he's he's examining and
covering
um you know just take a look at his his
four volume nietzsche lectures for
example right
so
yeah i mean
i think one big book is probably enough
right
uh idk what's your opinion on the role
of islamic medieval philosophers do you
think they are underappreciated in their
role in philosophy specifically by
western thinkers
yes and no i mean they're there in the
mix
if you're looking at thomas aquinas for
example
there's an aquinas in the arab projects
based right here in milwaukee at
marquette university um there are
they're graduate students studying with
richard taylor studying arabic so they
can read avaros and you know ibn cena
and people like that so i i think it
really depends on where you are
um
you know
you do need i think if you're going to
talk about them intelligently you do
need to like be able to read the
original language just as you would need
to be able to read latin
or
greek right
so that that's kind of an important
factor and that that probably holds some
people back right
um
are they unappreciated in some areas
yeah but um not not in others i'd say um
and you know the issue is often if
you're going to teach medieval
philosophy
how much can you actually cram into a
semester
i mean i i have to do triage every time
that i teach a class i can't teach
everybody who i'd like
so
all right uh
osh i found hattier's later ontology
with a replacement of identity with
difference in the event overall thinking
of things is similar to losers
difference in repetition
do you think he got influenced by
heidegger i mean everybody got
influenced by heidegger in one way or
another even loving us
who is uh directly opposing heidegger uh
and calling him out on stuff um sure
people people get influenced by all
sorts of people and heidegger is
influenced by kierkegaard and by
nietzsche and there's all these flows of
influence coming through people nobody's
like a self-made philosopher
[Music]
the question is always about how much
influence and what kinds of ways right
all right made of clay do you think a
philosophy degree works best in tandem
with another in this day and age i want
to get
my degree in philosophy and use it with
a career in mental health counseling so
i'd need to well yeah that's the kind of
path you're going on you definitely need
something in your content area
um just as if you are going to be you
know get a degree in philosophy and work
in a library also get a degree in
library science right or if you're going
to do
a degree in philosophy and yet you also
want to work in something where
mathematics is important or computer
science get a degree in that it's
usually it's pretty easy to double major
in philosophy and something else
philosophy degrees are fairly easy to
come by compared to some other ones um
so yeah that's that's that's usually a
good idea i got a degree in philosophy
and in mathematics not deliberately you
could say but just by inertia i like
taking both sets of classes i actually
did consider getting a major in history
as well because at the place that i was
going to my history of philosophy
classes would count for the major and
i'd taken a few others so all i would
need to do is take three more history
classes and i could have had a triple
major but i wanted to get out of school
so
so i didn't do that um
but yeah i think you know it wouldn't
hurt you to do that
um obviously
you know how long you stay in school and
how how to pay for it is sometimes uh an
issue for
for some people my oldest daughter who's
in college right now is like acutely
conscious even though she's going to a
place that's quite cheap to go to
university of wisconsin milwaukee she
wants to be done in those four years
right and i keep telling her it's you
know you don't have to rush it's not
that big of a deal you know but
sometimes people get that in their head
and that can that can constitute an
impediment right
so
um
yeah but if you're doing mental health
counseling you got to do like psychology
or counseling or something along those
lines don't you
all right uh t majo
um do you have a favorite frankfurt
school philosopher adorno from
horkheimer benjamin while you do core
concept video on the culture industry
well that's not a bad idea actually um
now everybody's everybody's always
asking me will you do a video on if i'm
going to do a work there's going to be a
whole set of videos because the whole
point of core concept videos is to go
through a work and isolate out some of
the key ideas arguments distinctions
and so you know
you can expect to see a series and the
culture industry wouldn't be bad to do i
mean
most of my core concept videos are
specifically on
um text that i'm teaching in class and
so like
this coming semester i've got to do some
more existentialism things like i'm
probably going to do kierkegaard's
sickness on to death so you can you can
expect to see some core concept videos
on that
and i might you know i might do a few
other authors i haven't hit on before
um
and then i'm teaching medieval
philosophy so i got to do some on
augustine do some on boethius
i've got someone and somebody got to do
more some on abellard some on
gregory the great my my namesake the guy
i was named after
i'm doing morelia and job just parts of
it and maybe some other things so you
know that's going to keep me kind of
busy for a while but yeah i could do
that now my favorite frogfort school
philosopher hands down it's adorno
adorno is very very difficult because of
the nature of his writing to
to do scholarship on i've found you know
i i published one article years and
years ago way back when i was
just out of graduate school
on adorno which has been incorporated
into some you know some texts and and
stuff like that
and that's the the last thing i've
managed to produce on a journal
in 20 years um but i do like adorno
i disagree with him about jazz of course
but
even do you have any favorite board
games card games or strategy games um
yeah card games you know my wife and i
have started just for for fun playing
rummy 500 that was a big favorite when i
was a kid
whenever you'd like be you know stuck in
a tent on a camping trip because it's
raining
or you know you know you're waiting in a
hospital for somebody who's sick or
stuff like that we play rummy 500.
i come from a family that was a big card
playing family so we used to play
pinocchio a lot i really enjoyed that we
would play up to eight-handed with three
decks sometimes and everything all the
way down to two-person pinocchio and
everything in between five five-handed
is probably my favorite
um
and we used to do that a lot before you
know all my older relatives died off you
know
so
we used to play cribbage a lot too you
know but most of the people i used to
play with are long dead again
um here in wisconsin of course
sheepshead is a big
card game i haven't played it for a long
time but that would be fun to do i used
to play a lot when i was in college as a
matter of fact we actually had a party
room where we played sheepshead about
three three nights a week and got you
know we'd drink beer and listen to music
and have a good time
um
board games um
i mean
the last board game that i played was
when my kids were here and we played
settlers of catan we also have some rick
and morty board games that are that are
fun too but we haven't played those for
a long time we haven't we haven't gotten
together as uh all three of us
uh
since covid hit so
yeah and and i haven't um i haven't been
out you know there's board game places
around here but
i just haven't gotten into doing that
but i i did enjoy that that sort of
thing
um
so yeah ruben says top three favorite
movies
i mean i love the duelist
that's an early ridley scott movie
after that it's kind of hard to say you
know
there's a lot of movies i've seen and
i'll think about them every once in a
while
i guess you could say what are my
favorite movies that have really really
stuck with me i mean maybe memento
christopher nolan's movie i used to use
it in class a lot
to discuss identity and memory
um
i'm trying to think of anything i've
seen that's really really good
that
massively impressed me
lately you know i saw the new dune movie
and i enjoyed it i wouldn't say it's
like one of my favorite movies but uh
people who are saying oh no good you
know
it actually was it's stuck pretty close
to the book there's some weird people
out there that are like there's some
sexual tension between paul and his
mother and i think there's some sexual
tension in their heads that they're
reading into the thing i didn't actually
see that in in the movie um i thought
that you know most of the scenes are
pretty well
done um you know it captures
kind of the the feel of the books so
yeah
all right so that's not really a full
answer but
the best i could provide
irony in crisis i wonder if you could
clarify your position on mindfulness i
noticed some skepticism in your early
hegel lectures but realize you see it as
part of the stoic tradition too yeah i
think a lot of the people that talk
about mindfulness are just full of [ __ ]
i mean it's woo-woo kind of stuff
at one spectrum there is some legitimate
mindfulness stuff but any legitimate
mindfulness stuff is almost always
within a spiritual tradition and it
becomes more woo-woo [ __ ] the more
that you
peel it out of that tradition and turn
it into its own thing i mean i know that
there's studies out there but there's
studies on everything right
and
it can be good to meditate but you don't
have to do mindfulness meditation
there's lots of other kinds of
meditation too
so the mindfulness industry i think is
[ __ ] and exploitative and elitist
and silly
mindfulness as something that's not that
okay but now you're talking about
mindfulness within a context and the
context matters
so
i think
i think i've been like super clear about
this the entire time you know um
i'll give you i'll give you one example
of one silly person so i participated in
this harvard study at the culinary
institute of america that was aimed at
like wellness and weight loss and all
these sorts of stuff and they put all
these different components together they
gave us a life coach my life coach
wasn't worth a [ __ ] because she was a
positive psychology person and a lot of
that's [ __ ] too you know some of it
isn't some of it is you gotta like see
through the the stuff that is and isn't
um
and uh they give you you know cooking
lessons from the chefs at the culinary
about healthy eating and some
demonstrations and you know hands-on
stuff and um they gave us gym membership
which was totally useless because it was
for a gym that was located on the other
side of the hudson river so we could
never make it there
and um
[Music]
they you know they'd take our bloods and
and do all sorts of readings every so
often and have us fill out all these
inventories and then they had a
mindfulness coach as well brought in and
the mindfulness coach was the typical
like
stereotypical hippie dippy
you know 60 something
talks in a soft voice
lady who was going to do mindfulness
with us and it was like a total failure
by the way when she's trying to lead
these culinary people who are all like
super type a personalities uh they had
actually increased their level of
anxiety
and unfortunately the guy who was in
charge of the study was captivated with
mindfulness he was another boomer too
you know boomers love mindfulness [ __ ]
and the the hippie dippy [ __ ] right and
so he was like always talking about we
need to be mindful of this and mindful
of that and after a while every time
that he'd say the word mindful everyone
would be like uh you could hear this
collective groan because there's a lot
of people who believe in it like they
believe in other panaceas
so
my bottom line mindfulness is good
in a context when it's connected with
other stuff on its own it's silly
[ __ ] and
there's also another aspect to it as
well which is it becomes a substitute
for actual medical care or psychological
counseling or all the other things that
should be provided and there's a lot of
you know let's provide people
mindfulness things at work and then they
can be better productive employees stuff
going on as well so i'm not i'm not a
fan of all that sort of stuff right
um
bill can we look at eternal recurrence
as a psychological trick
yeah i mean you can do anything you like
anything can be looked at in any way the
question is whether there's a legitimacy
to that and i mean what else could the
eternal recurrence be can you actually
like prove that that it's taken place or
anything like that i mean even the way
that nietzsche frames it it is not a
metaphysical assertion about reality it
is a put yourself into this sort of
mindset and imagine what would happen
hey if eternal recurrence does something
for you great i always found it to be
something that you know i i have zero
interest in the eternal recurrence of
the same quite frankly
um and i've never i've never found it to
be a particularly important or
interesting doctrine
i think a lot way too much gets made of
it
uh josh do you agree with popper that
all positions must be falsifiable no
because that position itself isn't even
falsifiable i mean this is one of the
problems with these people who have like
the one big thing that's going to like
solve things i mean look at air
verification principle right is that
verifiable no so you got a problem there
a sort of meta problem
and popper is is uh popper's a mix of
like interesting and well worth talking
about stuff and then absolute ridiculous
misreadings and mischaracterizations of
other other philosophers um i
i'm not saying you shouldn't read pauper
but
man was that guy a mess when it comes to
philosophy
all right rima what do you think of
merlot ponte especially in relation to
husserl and heidegger mariloponti is
much more readable than husserl or
heidegger
as a matter of fact interestingly in the
early days before husserl started
getting translated into french
people thought that mariloponte because
he'd studied with with withdrawal was
actually like a faithful representation
of glycerol
i think merlot ponti um his stuff is is
well worth reading and checking out and
thinking through i like the
phenomenology of perception
um
[Music]
merlot pontians because i've been to the
maryland ponte circle a couple times
kind of a mix of
rigorous phenomenologists and uh
he attracts a lot of woo-woo you know
new agey kind of people too
and then everything in between you know
so
all right uh
cork mars what is your assessment of
whitehead in process philosophy
um whitehead is an interesting guy you
haven't read um process and reality for
you know in whole for over 20 years so
that was a big thing when i was an
undergrad i worked my way through the
book probably didn't understand most of
what i was actually reading any more
than i did when i was you know reading
other people as an undergraduate like
sarts being in nothingness um i think i
thought it was cool stuff i might return
to it someday
um and i like whitehead's other stuff i
think that a lot of people
you know sort of like with hegel right
people are like oh i'm gonna have to
study hegel i gotta read the
phenomenology
probably not you probably should read
some other stuff before the
phenomenology because the phenomenology
is a tough book you know like with
whitehead you could read some of his
other easier books before you go to
process in reality and um you probably
benefit from it so you know that that
could
be a
an assessment i suppose um
kier levy do you think plato's
conclusions are relevant today his
assumptions that whoever knows justice
does justice makes it hard for me to
agree with almost all his claims well
that's that's silly for you to put it
like that
you should be able to handle him talking
about one thing without dismissing all
of his other claims
that's less about plato and more about
you
and so you probably want to rethink that
i wouldn't focus so much on plato's
conclusions and first of all
plato's conclusions where's plato in the
dialogues
do you do you have a guy who's actually
there as plato oh you're assuming
socrates is conclusions are uh plato's
conclusions right where are the
conclusions
are they always there or do they
sometimes leave things open and you have
to like draw your own conclusions
you want to think about this sort of
stuff before you
start generalizing about about plato as
a whole um or go to some some really
great commentators and see what they
actually
take plato's views to be
and see what what sort of uh
um
modes of argumentation there are for
them and what would be required on your
part to understand them you know because
platonism is not something where it's
like well you know
premise one premise two conclusion
that's not the way that platonic
dialogues work and that's not the way
that argument works in the real world
it's assumed that there's some work on
the part of the person as well as just
some some text there
right um
massacre would you consider heidegger an
atheist even though his philosophy is
ripe for christian appropriation
i wouldn't worry about whether heidegger
is an atheist i i don't see how that
matters at all
so that that would be my answer to it
reed besides being in time what do you
think are heidegger's best works you
know i haven't read all of heidegger's
work so i i probably am going to be off
on this
but i think his you know basic problems
of phenomenology is pretty pretty
awesome to read i like his uh nietzsche
lectures he's got lectures on all sorts
of other cool stuff as well some of
which i've read some of which i haven't
uh like his lectures on hegel's
phenomenology of spirit i kind of wish
that he hadn't ended them so early with
the self-consciousness section i would
love to see what he made of the spirit
section but
you know and then he's got like you know
phenomenology of the religious life he's
got a lot of great lectures on aristotle
so
you know there's some really wonderful
stuff you notice that the stuff i'm
talking about is pretty much early
heidegger and then and then
uh lectures i mean there's also some
great essays some of which i've done
videos on like you know what is
metaphysics that i use as my
introductory text for for people to
study heidegger
um
you know on the essence of truth the
problem concerning technology these are
all great works right so
um
what do you what's your opinion on kuhn
versus proper debate i don't have an
opinion so
um
[Music]
any suggestions on reading loving us for
a beginner
um yeah i mean expect that it's going to
be complex and difficult there isn't as
far as i know there's no like one single
text that you could say here's the place
to start with levinos but i'm not a
levyness scholar so i i don't i don't
really know and i don't read him very
often frankly
ben phelps views on hillary putnam and
the relatively recent influence of
pragmatism i don't have any views on
hillary putnam i mean he actually came
to my to my graduate school gave a talk
and i couldn't tell you what it was
about
um i don't think that i mean you can
study pragmatism without you know
studying hillary putnam i mean i just
brought up this book earlier right
um pragmatism has not gone away hillary
putnam is not the person responsible for
it not going away it's everybody else
who's reading
james and purse and royce and and dewey
and you know following them through into
the present so i i don't know
um
mike ron why do you think young people
and folks get attracted to
existentialist absurdist philosophy
so much and how does one get over it
i don't know that that it's uh there's
that many young people who are attracted
to existentialist or absurdist
philosophy
i mean i don't know that there's that
many people attracted to philosophy per
se among any generation
and why would you want to get over it i
mean how do you know that you should get
over it
i i'm still reading and rereading
existentialist texts in my 50s and
finding things that i missed when i was
into them as a teenager and 20 something
i mean some of the stuff
gets gets pretty old pretty quick like
think about waiting for godot by beckett
okay you read it once
it's it's it held up it was a great
canonical text but
i mean you read it once you you pretty
much tapped it out right
and that's actually much more absurdist
than it is existentialist existentialism
is serious philosophy and literature
about the problems of life looking at
things through uh a bunch of different
important concepts like anxiety and the
importance of emotions and you know the
centrality of looking at one's concrete
existence and thinking about death and
thinking about life and
all those sorts of things that's that's
serious philosophy a lot of absurdist
stuff degenerated just into people
saying random crap you know and uh
thinking that they were being somehow
liberated or profound
but you can reread sartre you can reread
nietzsche you can reread
you know kafka to take a literary figure
and get tons and tons out of it
throughout your life so why would you
want to leave it behind why wouldn't you
just want to
incorporate it into a larger life right
um
francisco's tomism generally generally
neglected in most philosophy
undergraduate programs if so why
almost everything is neglected in most
undergraduate philosophy programs so
there's nothing special about tomism
um even descartes is often neglected in
most philosophy programs you know like a
serious reading of descartes that goes
beyond meditations one and two
um
i mean
tomism probably you could say is on the
wane in catholic universities and and uh
colleges because uh people are kind of
tired of of thomas being a bunch of uh
elitist
uh gatekeeping jerks which they were you
know throughout the early 20th century
well into like the 80s there's lots of
great exceptions you know but um
you know there's a lot of mediocre
thomas out there just like there's a lot
of mediocre analytic philosophers
there's also you know an intersection of
them analytic thomas most of whom are
mediocre in my point of view and get
thomas wrong
but you know it
you could say the same of so many other
things as well i don't think there's any
sort of grand conspiracy against it
where you do see people paying a lot of
attention to thomas these days is
actually in in protestant circles where
they figured that they figured out that
they left a lot behind when they they
condemned him as like being the official
catholic philosopher which he never was
um
he was he was never the
one single approved philosopher
for for catholics so
um
[Music]
that's that's probably enough about
tomism
auntie what are some of your favorite
contemporary
philosophical sci-fi writers
that is tough for me to say because i
don't read a lot of contemporary sci-fi
if you mean like stuff that's been
published in the last 10 years
and i don't know who's philosophical and
who isn't i spend a lot of my time
reading stuff
that's much earlier you know up to like
the
70s and 80s
um so i don't i don't really have a good
answer to to that i mean if you're if
you ask me about fantasy i can give you
a little better
answer because i've read r scott backer
you know um
i mean when it comes to sci-fi i could
say okay i read octavia butler could she
be considered contemporary i guess so
you know
and i liked her stuff and it's quite
philosophical but
i i'm not i'm not reading a lot of new
stuff these days so
you know
um
idk what do you think about the argument
that stoicism leads to support for the
status quo
i think it's [ __ ] i think that
anybody who i mean you notice that you
wrote stoicism of the lowercase s
actual stoicism uppercase s
you know if you read it
it answers the question for you if you
think about the key people involved in
it was um musonius rufus just supporting
the status quo was epictetus saying just
support the status quo i mean read the
discourses within uh the very first two
of the discourses you've got a guy who's
opposing the emperor and saying well you
can kill me but i'm gonna i'm gonna go
to the senate and say what i have to say
um stoics took part in all sorts of
operations so this notion that it means
just supporting the status quo that's
not stoicism that's some sort of
caricature of stoicism and you got to
ask what's the agenda of the person
who's making these claims are they just
stupid lazy
they ignorant
because those are the only like ways
that you get them out of like
deliberately
um putting a fake picture forward right
so
yeah i don't i don't buy it um
i mean i'll say plenty of fake stoicism
and there is a lot of stuff that i'm i'm
willing to call fake stoicism
uh which is you know the people who are
selling coaching packages and they
actually they put all sorts of quotes
out there some of which aren't even by
the people that they're they're quoting
and they get epictetus's picture mixed
up mixed up with epicuruses because they
don't know [ __ ] right and they're just
trying to capitalize on stoicism that
sort of stuff is probably just going to
be about you know the status quo
although they want to make their way
into the status quo and make some money
but real stoicism no it's it's it's
definitely not just about supporting the
status quo i mean if the status quo is a
fair just wise status quo yes
how often is that the case
not very right
um
all right jared what do you think
democritus justification was for motion
since he considered motion as not having
to be explained
not a clue i i you know i think that
when it comes to these these thinkers
these pre-socratic thinkers who we don't
have their texts and we only have you
know fragments at best um we we probably
shouldn't try to
read too much in there and place our own
ideas about that into their their texts
so
um
max montague what's your opinion on
people trying to shoehorn in kant as a
deontologist
especially since i heard that some khan
scholars are challenging that
description of his ethics
i mean kant is as deontological as you
can get
so you can always find some scholars who
are challenging anything but who gives a
[ __ ] you know the mainstream of
scholarship on kant considers him to be
not just a deontologist but one of the
deontologists you know who is like the
the paradigm of the the very idea right
so i mean
that that one seems to be kind of a
non-starter to me
uh james carlisle do you prefer the us
or european phc system for philosophy a
longer one with classwork versus a
shorter one with just a dissertation
i don't prefer either because
i'm not in charge of that you know
so
here i'll tell you what my take is
i think that if you have the opportunity
to spend a lot of time on doing
coursework with
people who are very invested in you know
competent
uh presentation and analysis
of cortex in the history of philosophy
you would be silly to not take advantage
of that wouldn't you i mean when i was
in graduate school i took way more
classes than i actually had to and i
didn't just take classes with the
philosophy department i took them with
the classics department the english
department the speech communications
department
why wouldn't you
want to do as much coursework as you can
get i mean i even took coursework as
somebody who had a phd when when my wife
was studying at european graduate school
in uh sas face switzerland and i went
over there to visit her and they made me
a visiting scholar they said you can
take a class for free and i was like oh
that sounds cool i'm taking a class on
schopenhauer with wolfgang schermacher
because i never had a show open howard
class and this guy is the president of
the international chopin hierarian
society and the head of the school so
presumably he he knows some stuff why
wouldn't you
take classes if you have the opportunity
to take them with people that are good
why wouldn't you do that
you know
now on the other hand if your teachers
suck
it's not much good taking classes right
if they're a bunch of uh
you have to do things exactly my way
kind of jerks
maybe you just write the dissertation
then right but i don't think that that
there's an overall this is better this
is worse thing maybe some people don't
want to take classes you know and they
just want to write their dissertation
they're both they're both fine to do
right
all right majo do you think the shift
from society is a discipline to
society's control that deluse makes
drawing from pukawa unwarranted i mean i
think any of these big picture this to
this paradigm stuff we always got to be
kind of careful about right
so you know these things often turn into
slogans
justin was friedrich nietzsche an
atheist are you gonna do any more
self-directed study videos yeah i'm
gonna do self-directed study videos down
the line when i have the time was
friedrich nietzsche an atheist yeah he
was an atheist um i mean depending on
what your sense of atheism means
um he talks sometimes about divinities
but it's definitely not like you know
the idea of uh the god of abraham isaac
jacob but uh you know i mean who these
questions about is this person an
atheist is that person atheist who gives
a [ __ ] you know how is that how is that
particularly relevant to understanding
their their philosophy and its key
themes you know
um are what is your opinion about
this must be piranism yeah sextus's
arguments are still relevant in a sense
there's a strong aristotelian view like
aristotelianism criticism nichianism
i don't know what criticism is supposed
to mean
because that isn't that isn't a a strong
philosophical view or tradition
and i don't think there is anything like
nichianism there and aristotelianism is
a very broad spectrum so i'm not sure
what the connection is here but what's
your opinion about piranism
uh you know it's it's a very extreme
kind of skepticism um if i was gonna be
a skeptic i'd probably be much more of a
ciceronian skeptic you know attracted to
the or you know a human type of skeptic
um
actually hume has some good essays on
that that sort of thing why the hardcore
skepticism is kind of
self-refuting and problematic so
um and by the way you can be you can
certainly be skeptical in the lower you
know case sense uh of philosophical
perspectives you know in the sense that
you want evidence for them you don't buy
into them automatically without going
into skepticism right
of one form or another
all right um
uh just skipped a little bit let's see
where we were
um
man
things are kind of jumping around
um
okay francisco's got a good question
here
i think i have to scroll up a bit more
but i'll take this one right here if you
want to understand the philosophical
text could secondary literature properly
replace lectures and discussions with
your peers
i mean
if if you have to i mean
sure secondary literature if you're
using it right is you having a
conversation with the author about the
other author who is the primary thinker
why wouldn't you use as much as you can
why why would you
turn it into an either or though so
um
all right i scrolled back up to get to
where i was
uh
dracking thoughts on justice in plato's
republic compared to dante's inferno
um
i mean it's two that's apples to oranges
or actually apples to steaks or
something like that
um dante's inferno which is part of the
divine comedy right is part of how it's
sort of explaining how people are
getting what they deserve i mean the
only little connection between the two i
guess is like the myth of
uh that that's in the end of the the
republic about the trans migrations
right so i i don't see that as
um
a way to compare them
um
vener says
what do you think about intelligence and
spirit i've never read it so i i can't
say anything um
[Music]
novan would you please describe big
alien point of view about nothing and
being in god as the problem of the
beginning no i'm going to pass on that
because
i'm not even sure how i would start that
um sometimes the questions people are
asking for here in an ama are like you
know
stuff that you would have to take a
whole session to unpack and you don't
have the text in front of you
um
a doesn't equal a someone's making
polished renderings out of your
half-hour hegel series chalkboard
diagrams
they'll probably be available at the
marxist think tank website well that's
cool and and if somebody wants to
forward them to me i would love that um
i
don't envy the person
who is doing it because trying to
read my my shitty writing i've never had
good penmanship and i mean you see the
chalkboard behind me
um
it's just gotten worse and worse and
worse the older that i've got i've
actually got got a a problem with my
hands unfortunately
this like i it's a genetic thing this
muscle in here or tendons or whatever
get very tight and
eventually i'm probably going to lose
some control some motor control over my
hands and they hurt sometimes um
and you know i can i can get massage
done on them and stuff like that but
even my incredibly great body worker who
we're so fortunate to have
reaches limits and she's like this is
the best it's going to get so my writing
is terrible but yeah that's really cool
that people are doing that i'm kind of
kind of happy to see that
[Music]
even says i'm wondering if you'd share a
little bit about your writing process
how do you take your ideas and put them
into words systematically i don't have a
writing process
i just you know it's sort of like asking
a fish how do you swim
i don't know i i just i just do it
i uh you know and so asking somebody
like me is not very helpful
um asking you know for somebody like my
wife andy shaka who's a writing
instructor would probably be a lot more
helpful
um
i i don't unfortunately i don't have any
guidance for that
um
med says i just finished reading the ion
of plato's dialogues what next now the
meno the euthyphro the credo the apology
the fatal those are usually the those
are usually the six that i start people
with and then where you go from there
it's up to you do you do you like
rhetoric read the gorgeous and the
phaedras do you are you into
um you know talks about love and stuff
well read the lysius about friendship
and then the symposium and then the
phaedrus um
you know
it all depends on what your your
interests are you and there's no like
one single course you have to go through
for reading um plato
so
uh
sanita do you think that we need a
contemporary cunt-like figure to once
again close the gap between anglo-saxon
analytic and continental philosophy no
i think that's silly because who gives a
[ __ ] about that gap i mean continental
philosophy isn't just one thing it's a
whole bunch of traditions analytic
philosophy is now in post-analytic
philosophy where it's lost its roots and
its historical figures and you got all
these different people doing their own
thing
and they're not the only game in town
right um this all all this like bridging
the analytic continental gap so many
people have done that already habermas
does it record does it you know uh john
wisdom was doing it back in the 40s but
what about classical american philosophy
which isn't just pragmatism by the way
but also includes a transcendentalist
and the st louis hegelians and and and
what about the radical philosophy
traditions what about comparative
philosophy what about the tomists you
know and other uh
committed um
you know
religious uh philosophies what about
philosophy as a way of life all of these
are just as legitimate as continental
and analytic philosophy and do we need
some some person to unite the two i mean
did kant actually do that with
empiricism and rationalism anybody who's
told you that they they did is is
telling an old story that was you know
[ __ ] back then
uh it's a it's a cool little story but
that's like you know fairy tales
you know as far as the history of
philosophy goes um do we need somebody
like like that today why would we need
that you know i i that's just kind of a
non-starter for me
um
draken have you played magic the
gathering no but i've watched a lot of
people do it and enough to know that i
have no interest in it whatsoever
osh when you did math major what was the
most difficult math course and why galwa
theory we didn't have a class on galwa
theory
and you should know that there isn't
like a set math curriculum that
everybody has in every single school
across the board
i mean the most difficult one i would
say was probably either you know calc 3
or complex analysis
but the most fun one was a seminar that
we spent an entire semester on going
through um
douglas douglas hofstadter's gerda
escher bach and eternal golden braid
that was a lot of fun
um
francisco do you think that philosophy
is like math or chess in the sense that
to become proficient it's necessary to
start young
no
i i don't i don't think so at all and
you know
um
why would that be the case you know
people people have come to philosophy
very late in life and made some really
significant contributions so the history
doesn't even bear that out
um
let's see
oh paul asked do you have any thoughts
about the new dune movie i talked about
that a little bit i thought it was
pretty good you know i was i was
prepared to not like it
because there hasn't been a a really
good dune movie or mini series
but i i thought it was pretty good i
enjoyed it um i'm hoping that you know
it continues on as a franchise and i
can't say that about a lot of franchises
so
yeah
um
kartik i'm too intimidated to start to
start studying philosophy on my own how
can i you know i think i actually did a
video about that a while back um
about people who are intimidated to read
um
you should think about why you're
intimidated and whether you actually
have good reasons for it and then you
know get yourself to jump in it's sort
of like learning how to swim you got to
get in the water sooner or later or
decide you're just not going to get not
going to swim right
um
darth vader what do you think kant would
have thought of hegel building upon his
work i mean did hegel build upon kant's
work i don't see it that way ficta maybe
but i don't know that hegel is building
on kant's work
i think hegel is kind of doing his own
thing
using some ideas that come from this
broad movement of german idealism that
kant is a really important early figure
in but
man does hegel draw on a lot of
different resources so
um
[Music]
nl and and l is clearly edibilized or
you know has some wish fulfillment going
on there the mom was peeking at her
son's abs no doubt i mean
that's one of like 30 interpretations
that you could have come up with
probably says more about you than it
does about the movie right so
[Music]
uh
let's see here
darth vader could you tell us about
pinker being a schmuck those who aren't
from the west are ignorant because isn't
he like the guy who keep keeps blatantly
saying
things like everything is better and so
on
yeah i mean
pinker so pinker does a couple different
things right he's a popularizer he's a
popular writer his stuff is you know
sort of a mixture of stuff that can be
good and stuff that's that's
crap right
and he he's all about like you know the
importance of engaging critics but then
he doesn't engage critics right
um and that's you know i mean we could
go into other stuff like his unsavory
friendships and all that i mean he's
he's essentially part of an elite who
was in the right place at the right time
with the right face and the right
contacts and made it big and thinks that
he knows better than than other people
and um you know some people do know
better than other people but i wouldn't
bet that it's stephen pinker
so
you know that makes him a schmuck um i
think that's probably
easy enough
bulky have you read
uh
il yankoff i have not read alien cough
um
all right let's see here
um
a lot of people asking about people i've
never i've never read so
um
darth vader what do you think is the
overlap between psychoanalysis and
philosophy
do you think psychoanalysis like
philosophy starts from a
phenomenological point of view without
any presuppositions find me a
philosopher whoever began without any
presuppositions and what we could have
that conversation then and you're never
going to find one because they don't
exist
philosophy doesn't always start from a
phenomenological point of view
phenomenological points of view are one
tool that philosophy has there are many
different starting places for philosophy
what do you think is the overlap between
psychoanalysis and philosophy which
psychoanalyst are you talking about
which philosophy are you talking about
those are all things you'd have to
clarify
um blaze do you find ggx incorporation
of psychoanalysis and a german idealism
useful for your understanding of hegel i
do not
um i find reading hegel helpful for my
understanding of hegel that is that is
the basis that i come back to over and
over and over again
um
i you know i will read secondary
literature on hegel every once in a
while which sometimes i'm like oh yeah
yeah that's a good point there is nobody
who's like take on hegel i think is
determinative for understanding hegel
just like you know if you want to
understand aristotle read aristotle if
you want to understand what camus is
saying read camus
secondary lit can be helpful and it can
often be quite interesting but and
insightful
but
it's not it's not there's no key
to reading a primary text other than
reading that primary text i think you
know
uh g b t g i think it's fair to say dr
salter does not abide mindfulness i mean
if you got that from my you know five
minute talk on it you you weren't paying
attention
i super clear
you know new agey mindfulness all by
itself that's garbage you know
mindfulness as a substitute for actually
providing people with psychotherapy that
they need that's garbage too
mindfulness within a context that's not
garbage that's actually quite helpful um
so you know
i think people got to avoid these very
extreme you know it's this way or it's
this way sort of thing and develop some
like nuance that that's if you want to
be a philosopher
you got to be able to say well yes but
also no
if we understand it this way
distinctions
are
you know the the probably the most
important skill that we philosophers
bring to the table is the ability to
make needed distinctions and to do so
well
you know when i'm doing work with
clients you know who are not trained
philosophers it's as if they think that
we're magic because we can do that you
know it's not all the memorization of
concepts and having read through primary
text that's all great that's useful
being able to thoughtfully make
distinctions and not have a one-sided
point of view
is massively important right
so yeah
all right
um
let me scroll down there's people
talking about eternal recurrence
uh darth vader says would love to see
you talk hegel with zizek would you ever
be open to discuss philosophy and
theology with the g-sex someday
you know people ask me these sort of
things and i think what they don't
understand is
this is kind of a nice pipe dream if you
want to make it happen
then ask me after you've got g-shack on
the line
and you know then then it's a live
possibility the idea that these people
up in the stratosphere of celebrity are
going to engage with people down here
like me
is kind of kind of silly you know
um they don't do that they engage with
other people up there on top
um
i mean
i could possibly if i went back to egs
you know
run into xiz somewhere and then he'd
he'd treat me like the uh
uh you know i mean he treats his
students like like crap you've read
about him and his you know don't send me
your shitty papers what makes you think
you'd want to talk to somebody like me
you know i mean obviously if he wanted
to do it and somebody set it up sure i'd
be game for that
um but in what universe is that ever
going to happen
so
yeah um
all right looks like uh
we got some some goofy
stuff here so i gotta uh
take care of of uh one of the people
who's spamming the thing
all right um
let's see what else we have
um paul asks i've read that all we know
about socrates is written by plato so
that's false wherever you read that they
they are selling you a line
is it possible that socrates is a
fictional character created by plato to
explain his philosophical ideas so this
is basically the mythicist thing applied
to socrates if you don't know what
mythicism is it's this crazy notion that
there never was a jesus guy it was all
made up
no i mean
do we do first of all who do we know
about socrates through
well um plato and xenophon and through
other you know uh lineages as well so
there isn't anybody in ancient times
who's like you know i think maybe maybe
socrates is just made up or something so
whatever source you got that from you
want to quit listening to them i think
or start looking them with with a very
critical
lens
um
we know a lot about socrates you know
and we we know enough about him to know
that he made a massive
impression and influence on people that
could lead to different pictures of
socrates you know xenophon's picture of
socrates is not the same thing as
plato's picture of socrates and then the
other ones that sort of come through
other sources which which presumably are
fairly reliable are highlighting other
aspects of this guy socrates so
all right marx has been thinking about
techne as excellence lately any
discussions
of techne by contemporary virtue
ethicists you recommend that's a good
question
i mean nothing like pops into my head uh
as like a study of
aristotelian understandings of techne as
as such
um
i mean there are fragmentary stuff
within the stoic thing but
there's there's not you know in the
ancient uh stuff there's it's like
techne often gets de-emphasized quite a
bit i suppose except by the people who
are doing technes like rhetoricians you
know rhetoric was considered a techne so
maybe we want to look at people that are
saying something about lysius or or um
you know cicero's a good person for for
that but yeah unfortunately nothing
nothing really comes to mind
but i'm not reading a lot of
contemporary virtue ethics stuff either
these days you know
all right quark mars what do you think
of the carmadees and the meaning of
sofrosinae so the carmadees is a early
dialogue by plato they're trying to
figure out what sulfrosana or temperance
means and it's an aperitic dialogue
so it you know it's kind of like all
over the map and and they can't figure
out a proper um
solution of what what things are but
they they go some interesting places
along the way they kind of show us that
the idea of there being a knowledge of
knowledge isn't quite going to work um
so it's it's plato playing around with
with some ideas you know i think if you
want to find out what plato really
thinks about temperance the place to go
is the republic right uh where there's
there's discussion of it in
primarily uh books
two through four so
jaden watson says uh do i have any
thoughts on the tao
which tao are you talking about i mean
the tao of taoism or the many other ways
in which people have invoked that you
know with like cs lewis talking about
there being a dow lying behind things
i mean
it's it's one of those uh important
concepts when we're actually looking
into taoism that we have to go to the
primary text and see what they say and
much of what they say is paradoxical
um
do i think there's anything myself like
what what the taoists call the dao
um
you can't even say really underlying
reality but encompassing all reality
i don't i i don't think that that there
is um
any any more than i think that there's a
logos that pervades everything you know
the way that that some of the ancient
stoics did right
um so yeah
um
scroll down a bit
irony says for hagel you say to start
with the easier works before the
phenomenology of spirit where do you
recommend you start is it necessary to
read kant understand hegel i'll say it
this way can't hurt
can't hurt to read aristotle understand
hegel right there's a lot of people that
it would be useful to read before
reading hegel um kant is not absolutely
essential
in importance reading rousseau would
probably be very helpful as well
um i recommend reading the lectures on
the history of philosophy because then
you can get like hegel's take on what
philosophy is about and how it developed
and reading the lectures on the
philosophy of history those are my
two go-to's
uh and i make this recommendation a lot
when people are are asking that sort of
question
um i mean you could read other things by
hegel
there's earlier works
you know there's also reason in history
which gives you a little bit of his
his uh uh system you could say but i i
think those two are the the best
uh darth vader which tradition school of
philosophy other than stoicism aligns
with your personal values and lifestyle
i did a whole video on how i'm a
ciceronian eclectic a while back
so obviously cicerodian eclecticism
which is not a system but is sort of an
attitude
um you know i draw heavily on aristotle
i draw heavily on the platonus tradition
which includes not just plato but the
middle plateness like plutarch and you
know neoplatonus going all the way into
christian neoplatonism
draw heavily on the existentialists i
draw heavily on dialectical philosophy
um
you know there's there's a number of
a number of different sources that i'm
pulling from i like some things in
descartes i like some things in pascal
i even like some things in hume you know
so there's there's a lot of different
traditions and schools of philosophy
that that i draw on but if you if i had
to describe my overall attitude
you know i would say that sort of like
aleister mcintyre i'm a virtue ethicist
and i understand virtue ethics as not
just like a you know a system that can
be reduced to axioms the way that crazy
people try to do with it where it's
really a weird kind of code it's more
like you know what he calls tradition
constituted rationality this vast
conversation that we participate in and
try to make sense out of our our lives
and our our
obligations and relationships through
and then we we draw upon you know
whoever's got something valuable so you
know mcintyre
in in uh some of his essays will say
here's what we need to draw on from jon
stewart mill here's what we need to take
from kant you know
um so that that's kind of my my point of
view and that i think that is rather
ciceronian if you look at how cicero
himself
works out his his philosophy
all right craig says do i have a
recommendation for learning contemporary
philosophy of 20th century
for example contemporaries edmund
hussrill simone de beauvoir ein rand
badu chomsky
um so those those a lot of them are not
21st century philosophers right um
husserl died a long time ago de bouvoir
lived past that into the 80s but she's
long dead ein rand is long dead but dew
and chomsky are around but they're both
old old guys right uh probably about as
old as mcintyre
um
who's i think 93 now um
do i have recommendations for learning
contemporary philosophy yeah and my
recommendations i think the thing i
would start with at the at the very
beginning is
you know read their books but don't read
them
as as like a joiner a believer you know
don't become a bad you yen read what bad
you has to say
uh because before you're really gonna
get what he's saying you're gonna have
to do some back story stuff and
and read you know
going back before the 20th century
because these people are referencing you
know for example plato um
i i think that
you do you have to read all of plato's
works before you can read any
contemporary stuff no no um but you do
need to know some things about what
plato actually thought so when they talk
about platonism you're not you know
you're not at sea like you know there's
there's a lot of criticism of platonism
in 20th century european philosophy
and there's also some endorsement i mean
iris murdoch right um
great 20th century novelist and
philosopher
um so you know reading reading the
backstory stuff um and and not not
reading it in the way
where the the people in the present who
are criticizing it sour your your
reading of it so like when you read
descartes for example you want to read
descartes and take seriously the idea
that somebody could think these thoughts
and they're not just crazy and they're
not you know just a representative of
modernity and it's iron cage of
rationality you want to like read them
and
and you know be sympathetic to them and
and not everybody has to be
all right at the same time you know you
couldn't do that unless you were
containing multitudes in a whitman kind
of way
but that will enrich your understanding
of the the contemporary thing or so
chomsky for example chomsky endorses a
kind of
cartesian based thing when it comes to
to language having to do with innate
ideas you know um
and then the other thing i would say
that's important
you can't read everybody
so you don't have to feel as if
you have to
find all of the important 20th and 21st
century thinkers and read through them
all
that that's just not feasible
um
probably can't even do that with the
important thing because of the 19th
century there's a lot of them too
so you gotta you got to be selective you
know you you decide where you want to
put your time and attention and it may
be that there's some philosophers
who
aren't as rewarding for you and that's
okay you know so i am working uh
through
varieties of religious experience with
one of my clients
um
who you know decided he wanted to work
on that book and we meet every two weeks
and we go through some of the chapters i
have another client who tried to
read the varieties of religious
experience on his own and found that he
just couldn't accept it this is a guy
who does work in religious studies
and he's like i can't read this crap
right now it's the same book right
different readers are coming to it with
different things so
you know if you're reading um
i mean husserl is very boring
but worth reading in parts um he's an
interesting guy he
introduces some good ideas but you know
jeremy bentham is also very boring to
read
unless you really get into it right
um but well worth doing simone de
beauvoir is a lot more fun
i think william james is a lot of fun
myself
but some people don't like him
so as you're approaching these things
you can you can look at it
as these are opportunities for you to
engage with an author see what they have
to say
you don't have to buy into everything
that they're saying you know
there's there's always going to be some
things that you find
implausible or you know maybe even
offensive it kind of goes back to that
comment earlier about about where the
guy was saying you know plato says this
and i can't accept that he he says this
about justice and somebody who says that
about justice he must be wrong about
everything else well no no um you can
kind of pick and choose you you you
don't have to
accept everything that an author says
you can take some useful things from it
um the other thing i'll say as well
because i don't want to spend you know
too much time on this
um
books classic books reward rereading
what does that mean well
great works of literature like again
varieties of religious experience or you
know i'm kind of it's not too bad i
don't have other books lined up over
here that i can do that with
um
you're gonna find
things that you missed the first time
around
and
actually you know i will i do have
another book so i reviewed recently this
book by elliot rosenstock the ego and
its hyper state very thin book right
came out from zero books just this last
week
and um
the first time that i read it
in order to do a sadler's honest review
this is also by the way a book that's
you know psychoanal psychoanaly
psychoanalytically informed dialectical
analysis a lot of a lot of continental
jargon kind of stuff involved there
right um the first time i read it i was
like yeah i i think some of these things
don't actually
work together i'm not that happy with
the book the second time i
re-read it i was like oh now i see how
the parts fit okay this this is actually
a pretty good book
so there's a lot of things like that you
know as you're reading say husserl or
badu
or chomsky where that's going to happen
for you right
and sometimes you you got to put the
book down and go do something else for
an hour a day a week a month and then
come back to it and you'll you'll get
something different
out of the book as a result
um
and maybe one other thing try to look
for resources that are out there there
was a
you know question earlier about reading
secondary literature versus like going
to videos and stuff like that
use it all you know
um if if you find that there's somebody
out there i i don't you know watch a lot
of other people's videos because
taking the time to produce videos cuts
into my day
but if there's somebody out there who
explains bad u very well
watch their videos or read their blog
posts or
get their books or things like that
i mean with badou
or chomsky
you could also write to them
they may not respond to you
but they are still alive and you could
talk to them whereas simone de beauvoir
she's dead you're never going to get an
answer out of her right or or edmund
wiserel or any other um
past philosopher like that so hopefully
that's that's that's useful for you
um
[Music]
we're getting close to the end of the
hour and i've got another event coming
up later on
let me see if i can take some some
questions about uh they're from other
people that i haven't
gotten anything from um
here's a funny name darth vegan
what would your entrance music be if you
met evil sandler in a wwe match
well there there is some entrance
there's a song that i would like to be
my entrance music
no matter what if if i ever got
you know the rights to use it
i would like to walk out to
zero the hero you know by black sabbath
it's a great song great riff and
i like the lyrics so
yeah
uh dylan are you interested in the
writings that come from theravada
buddhism i mean the texts that conform
to the polycon and the nikayas etc yeah
i'm interested in them i don't have as
much time to to read
stuff like that and obviously i have to
read it in translation because i don't i
don't read
the languages that they're written in
so yeah
um
raul says would you say there is a shift
for the worse and foucault's later life
specifically when he talks about
practices of the self care of the self
and notion of parasia
i don't think it's a shift for the worse
i think there is definitely a shift
there i i think
on the one hand foucault plays fast and
loose with the ancient texts and
thinkers that he's using right so don't
rely on him as a faithful
interpreter of ancient philosophy
um but on the other hand there's some
interesting stuff that he is he is
drawing to our attention
and i kind of like that stuff i mean if
i have to choose between the history of
sexuality and the order of things the
order of things is going away even
though it's a really cool book
you know it's probably his most
structuralist book by the way um so yeah
there is there is definitely a shift and
foucault himself says that there's
there's a shift going on
um
guru damarang says what are some
problems you see with foucault's ideas
you said before you doubt he will be
read much in the future i've actually
said the opposite i think that dairy dog
won't be read much in the future but
that foucault will
um
some of the problems with foucault's
ideas i just signaled one um
his use of
historical texts and thinkers is is
often quite suspect especially if you
know the stuff that he's talking about
you know i'm not a criminologist but i
have quite a few criminologist friends
and when they look at you know um the
birth of the prison they're in
discipline and punish they're often like
um yeah some of this story is true but
some of it isn't so there's you know
like with any anybody who's doing
historical interpretation
there's there's some
places where the narrative might not
really be as as cut and dried as
foucault makes it out to be
um
[Music]
i mean obviously
getting himself sick and dying and
cutting short his life was a foolish
thing on his part if he really had a
big project that he was working on so
that's that's kind of a an issue right
um
all right let me scroll down here
see who else we haven't
gotten to before
um
[Music]
tom mcdowell says bentham is so turgid
if you can struggle through it there's
some excellent dry wit in his later work
there is actually actually even even in
his early work there's there's a lot of
good dry wit
um
but
he loves these endless lists of things
and and you can say why does he do that
well he's he's trying to use lists as
part of an argument to show i've covered
everything that could be covered it's a
way of saying i'm i'm being
comprehensive you know
so
um
all right uh
muhammad says what do you think of mock
sterner and the young hegelians of his
time do you think they took hegel in an
interesting direction
i mean i don't think they took hegel in
an interesting direction i think they
took hegelian ideas and language in an
interesting direction
sterner is is you know i i enjoy reading
his stuff someday i may do videos about
it i actually have thumbnails that i
made a long time ago when i was working
with a client on going through
um uh the ego and its own ego and its
property
but um
i don't know i think stronger is kind of
a dead end frankly unless you just want
to be an egoist like that um
so you know it's uh
there's a lot of cool stuff happening
in
i guess you could call it hegelian slash
posthagelian philosophy
um
you know
foyerbach is really cool to read i think
that he articulates hegel's views on
religion particularly well
and calls out what's what's really
happening there i think foirbach is a
faithful interpreter of hegel in that
respect
um
obviously marx you know there's all
these other hegelians that are more
obscure that are that are fun to read
so
um
sam asks what is the crux of the
disagreement between delusions and
hegelians i don't know i mean i i don't
i don't i don't know that there is
actually
a
um
coherent group out there that we would
call the hegelians that get to speak on
the part of hegel
um i mean if it has to do with like the
you know historical developments hegel
obviously was wrong about a lot of stuff
um
and delusions seem to be all over the
map you know i'm not sure that there's
any coherent delusion movement there so
i don't really know it's a good question
michael asks as well aside from after
virtue what do you think is aleister
mcintyre's most important single piece
of written work
i don't i i would say that after virtue
is
um
[Music]
you know if you think about the the
four book series
whose justice which rationality is
probably
more important than after virtue more
important in the sense of like the ideas
are being worked out more fully there
and then you can see dependent rational
animals
and
three rival versions as like
amplifications of that
unfortunately after virtue is the one
that everybody reads
but i think you can see after virtue is
like something flowing into the much
much more robust
um who's justice which rationality you
know
so
yeah and and
i think it's good if you if you're
really interested in mcintyre as a
thinker
you do want to read his stuff before
after virtue like his history of ethics
is quite quite interesting
and often quite good
[Music]
against the self images of the age you
know
those sorts of things are all
quite quite interesting to check out
um
so yeah those those are all
those are all
quite good um now ray points something
out that's kind of interesting here
deleuze is already totemic
and on the same level as foucault yeah i
think that a lot of these thinkers
like to lose with or without qatari
spinoza hegel
um
marx also um
they are they they function in that's a
good word totemic people identify with
them and it's part of like their team
and they
they get some ideas about like what
hegel is actually saying but they don't
they don't spend a lot of time
systematically studying
hegel and i think that a lot of people
who talk about duluth are not really
systematically working their way through
loses stuff and to lose his stuff with
qatari they're kind of picking and
choosing the things that look cool so
then they pick up on on terminology like
the body without organs everything's a
body without organs well the body with
or without organs i think is an
incoherent idea quite frankly it's
something that sounds really cool but
but uh you know
i've read to lose and um i if you ask me
what the hell it is there's a whole
bunch of different answers and that's
not satisfying to somebody like like me
right and i think you can say there's
similar things about hegel right um you
could talk all you want about
determinant negation or the negation of
the negation and that could mean
anything you want it to mean it becomes
this it's almost like a consumer product
right and we exchange it among ourselves
and that's not that's not doing real
theory or philosophy i would say
um
all right let me scroll let me take a
couple more minutes i gotta i gotta get
some lunch before i
hold my next thing but i wanna see if
there's some other
good um
things i can i can pick up on from from
other people here
let's see here
so jordan says i know a philosopher
who's good friends with g-jack and he
knows doc who's dr sadler is i think
it's very possible to set up so yeah if
you want to do that
be my guest
um
let's see
let's hear tarzan give us three movie
recommendations okay now that's easier
than ant than saying what's your
favorite movie
so
you know
i would say you know there's all these
great adaptations of philip k dick
stories and novels
like scanner darkly i i think scanner
darkly was a pretty good adaptation now
you gotta like rotoscope
my wife won't watch it because she it
makes her sick to watch rotoscope which
is unfortunate
um i i mentioned memento earlier i used
memento quite a bit in classes when i
was teaching
i you know back in the time when it was
really cool to talk about descartes
and the evil demon and
the matrix i didn't show the matrix i
would show dark city instead which is a
lot more fun i think
than the matrix
and you know i i like a lot of older you
know like neo-noir movies i get into
that sort of stuff
um
as well
um
trying to think if there's anything
that's really really impressed me lately
[Music]
nothing really comes to mind oh now
here's a great question
um
captain of the nerd guard what do you
think about the creeping nihilism that
is occurring in cartoons nowadays like
an adventure time
so
i haven't watched adventure time for a
long time because my kids used to watch
it when they were young and then they
kind of grew out of it
but there's a lot of cartoons where you
can say
there's it's i don't know if it's
nihilism as such
but there's there's this
and it's it's not just in cartoons it's
also in some live-action shows it's like
absurdism
uh
you know
happening over and over and over again i
mean there is also the
this is something that would actually be
worth talking about at considerable
length you know doing a sort of media
analysis there's also this sort of like
we didn't learn any lessons
um great example of a show where that
happens all the time is always sunny in
philadelphia which is a show i love you
know and i love it because i actually
enjoy that sort of comedy
my wife has a more limited tolerance for
that um
but the like people acting
you know in in weird or or screwed up or
obsessive ways
and things happen but there's really no
there's really no resolution that runs
through things
um
[Music]
yeah there is that in a lot of cartoons
um more when they're oriented towards
adults
less for kids i would say
um but a lot of cartoons are hitting
things on two levels right
like you know when my when my daughter
was obsessed with kim possible i enjoyed
watching kim possible uh a good bit
because it was also good for for adults
i'll also admit too that you know i knew
uh nicole sullivan from mad tv
era and her portrayal of she-go was was
quite fun as well so there's like a
familiarity effect too to that but yeah
i mean there
there is a i don't know if we have to
call it nihilism as such
but there's definitely a
a undermining of traditional
narratives which might have been all
[ __ ] too
um going on within
comedy media
and it opens up the door to other things
happening you know i just watched my way
through this british show zapped which
is about a guy who's an office kind of
drone and he gets he gets transported
he's actually a courier yeah he gets
transported into another dimension it's
kind of like a fantasy
thing there's some cool characters
and nothing really works in the end but
there's some really great
storylines and there's the opportunity
for relationships to develop
and
for you know tenderness sometimes to be
shown towards people or or you know
there's just because things happen in a
universe that doesn't have an automatic
making sense narrative to it doesn't
mean that everything
becomes meaningless
it means you have to work for it i mean
this is sort of the existence we could
say that there's there's a
i'll i'll end on this maybe there's a
tension between a kind of
nihilist and an existentialist
motif in both of these that's different
than it would have been
if it was done in 1940
you know we're living in a much more
complex
world both in terms of economics and
culture and media and and all of that
sort of stuff so
all right so i think that's a good thing
to end on um i got 20 minutes to shove
some food in my face before i gotta get
onto my next thing thanks everybody for
showing up uh i've enjoyed this we'll
we'll have you know we have these every
month we've got other events coming up
including the political theory and
practice discussion in which i'll be
talking about gerrymandering and why
it's such a bad thing for
democracies
we got a couple other things coming up
as well so i'll see all of you in the
ether somewhere